Brazil spent 365 million dollars to
build this new stadium in some follow
for the World Cup but just two miles
away far beyond the sound of screaming
fans there's this so tell me what's
going on here Kim I think rezero
cucarachas Kisame Itachi down one girl
should be moved to the space was no
poder piranha girl pretty nervous omocha
Paso del Ruchi Vegeta Yasuo more Aegean
Elena de Silva claims her rent doubled
overnight from about $200 a month to
$400 too poor to pay and with nowhere
else to go she came here
how many people were here at the
beginning and how many people are here
now new Biswas I've already something
about the new campus I needed they're
all spotting on this land the residents
say they're part of the homeless workers
movement the temps may be nothing more
than plastic sheeting but each has a
number like an address by occupying
private land and abandoned buildings the
squatters are trying to shame the
government into building more affordable
housing
city officials estimate that more than
230,000 some paulo families need shelter
and yet they plan to build only
fifty-five thousand new homes over the
next two years the people here call this
tent city new Palestine aren't the
living conditions difficult are you not
worried that it'll come to the point
that it's too dangerous to live here
Riccardo Muti kg well that for you and
move you away to have them as Ilona
taught American Water has to be brought
in and there's no electricity communal
kitchens handout donated food entire
families eat and sleep in the same room
how is it on the children schedules
budgets mom nice collar only scholar
goodbye huh
can we keep the gym and cook you a sec I
will go blamin opening on the night of
the inaugural match and sound Paulo's
new stadium a torrential downpour halted
play for almost half an hour a minor
inconvenience for fans a disaster for
residents of the tent city Sousa Ravenna
Jame olia stocking Pablo Picasso real
movie star John Cena's Camino de negocio
de Janeiro same kb+ across three meters
in motors more ideas the squatters
staged a protest outside the San Paolo
Stadium a week before the World Cup
exposure they hope will drive the
Brazilian government to act faster
how long you prepared to stay